[Musique]
delta crohn cette possible fusion des
variantes deltalyo mikron a affolé les
réseaux sociaux ce week end une équipe
de chercheurs chypriote affirme avoir
identifié 25 cas de co-infection omikron
et delta on a quelques semaines
difficiles à passer mais sur le long
terme au micron et la situation
sanitaire n'affecteront pas la
croissance française anne en 2022 ce
sera un artiste de long terme je reste
tient nos prévisions de croissance à 4%
mais des scientifiques exprime déjà des
doutes sur l'existence de ce variant
pour le virologue britannique tom
peacock les séquences génétiques serait
le résultat d'une contamination
inséparables jusque dans la mort les
obsèques des frères bogdanoff les
jumeaux les plus célèbres du paf âgé de
72 ans est décédé à six jours
d'intervalle de kobe ont été célébrées
cet après midi en l'église de la
madeleine à paris les militants anti pas
se lancer des algues et des pierres sur
stéphane clair aux députés et les oem de
saint pierre et miquelon il parle de
lapidation et annonce évidemment son
intention de porter plainte et la
lâcheté la lâcheté face à un homme seul
un homme qui était pacifique qui était
sans défense et qui a fait face et qui
est sorti qu'a voulu parler qui les
invite à parler ils ont refusé sur
twitter des images circulent montrant
les pousses du député elle y ferait un
doigt d'honneur aux manifestants une
photo qui aurait été prise après les
jets de projectiles j'ai une pensée
toute particulière pour notre député st
pierre et miquelon qui a été agressée
ces dernières heures à son domicile de
manière intolérable par certains de nos
compatriotes et qui après beaucoup
d'autres élus à uche a eu à subir de
manière inacceptable c'est ces violences
s'agit pas d'un déplacement présidentiel
il s'agit d'un déplacement électoral
donc je crois qu'à un moment il faut il
faut dire la vérité il faut très
clairement ne pas prendre les français
pour des idiots monsieur macro est
candidat le bilan du maquereau nisme
c'est un waterloo
sécuritaire emmanuel macron a laissé la
société sanche sauvage et eva laissait
aux français une france orange mécanique
marine le pen dit que vous étiez un
chien perdus sans collier vous avez
trouvé votre collier non mais j'ai
entendu certains pas tous ordres je
regarde beaucoup de mes amis de l est
rejeté j'avais des qualités à 9h59
irais-je et que dd mais mardi c'est un
épiphénomène et je garderai mon amitié
quand même vous voyez la politique c'est
fade et ce sont des choix qui sont
parfois différents des uns des autres ce
n'est pas mon choix je pense qu'il fait
une grande erreur la seule personne qui
est capable de battre emmanuel macron
c'est valérie pécresse sûrement pas eric
zemmour zemmour macron qu'est ce que tu
fais valérie on est d'accord tu vois tu
pas macron à bompas voilà moi je ne veux
pas emmener les électeurs de droite vers
emmanuel
patrick buisson par sarah knafo près son
candidat de le rattraper pour la photo
valérie ressemblent en tellement de
points à emmanuel macron même bruno le
maire et gérald darmanin le dise et donc
si on veut une vraie rupture si on veut
tourner la page du maquereau nisme il
faut soutenir eric zemmour
[Rires]
de l'ong flammes s'échappent d'une
fenêtre de ce bâtiment en briques dans
le bronx la fumée très épaisse s'est
répandu dans les dix neuf étages les
deux cent vingt pieds sur place tente de
sauver les habitants l'un d'eux porte un
nourrisson dans les bras
des rescapés ont entendu les appels à
l'aide désespéré de leurs voisins un
avion s'est écrasé sur une voie ferrée
son pilote a été extrait in extremis par
les policiers quelques secondes juste
avant qu en train de perdre tout
l'appareil
l'ascenseur avec quelques coupures et
kimmo seulement aucun passage du train
n'a par ailleurs été blessés
[Musique]